it's been one week since isolation and
we are finally blessed with some Kelly
okey if I could recapture all of the
memories and bring them to laugh about
damn time yeah yeah Kelly Clarkson
performed a rendition of Mariah Carey's
1990 song vanishing and of course the
Queen herself shall tell me some love on
Instagram I was very honored but before
we get into that let's rewind the TV
host took her social distancing to
Montana there's nowhere to go or in like
a little cabin in Montana so we have a
ranch here so hair tied singing with no
makeup on Kelly belted out in her
bathroom
that's a towel it's my husband's town
I'm in a bathroom that's cool
I feel like I'm back in high school
Kelly dedicated the video to Mariah who
she feared grilled over on this week's
The Voice probably vanishing oh my gosh
girl that's like Mariah then jumped on
Twitter and wrote Kelly I'll take your
track 5 Q Kelly okey
[Music]
Johanssen so far away I mean she crushed
it Mariah was so impressed she commented
I know you're usually working 30 hours a
day eight days a week so this must be
quite an adjustment for you as it is for
us all keep the videos coming
she even put in a request for Kelly to
sing whenever you call next
[Music]
I'm just saying Kelly if you need a
Brian McKnight call me but while we're
all patiently waiting Kelly had a sweet
message for the fans we're gonna get
through it this is just a really crappy
time but that's okay we're gonna get
through it and count on our girl
to keep it real we have a lot of kids
and we've been doing school every day
and we've been cooking every meal which
I don't generally do but you know what
everything tastes great when a om sauce
is involved it's not that good at
cooking
[Music]